you
breaking up the Yemeni State is better
than fighting to keep it together right
it's an appealing thought and not
unprecedented Yemen used to be two
countries the north and south united in
1990 southerners started in loss of
civil war in 1994 and a secessionist
movement re-emerged in 2007-2008 and the
front line of today's war is along the
old north-south border
redefining Yemen won't bring peace or
remove Iran's and Al Qaeda's footprints
in the north there will be a contest
between the former Yemeni President Ali
Abdullah Saleh and the Iranian backed al
Houthi movement regardless of who wins
the AL duties will keep a state live in
the north preserving Iran's influence
who provides much-needed financial
support to the north remains an open
question
Saudi Arabia won't and Iran can't the
other half of the country the south is
far from stable an ongoing power contest
among various factions including the
internationally recognized Yemeni
government will distract from any
concerted effort against Al Qaeda
instead of solving Yemen breaking up the
state just replicates the problems what
do you think the future of Yemen looks
like let us know in your comments also
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds and
be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI